Shure: 为什么写着原浆荞麦啤酒3元一罐
Shure: Why does it say raw buckwheat beer is 3 yuan a can?
Jake:为什么写着南江九百米
Jake: Why does it say 900 meters to Nanjiang?
Shure: 而打开冰箱却一罐啤酒都没有
Shure: But when I open the fridge, there's not a single can of beer.
Shure: 为什么为什么
Shure: Why, why?
Shure: 配上这个音乐就
Shure: With this music, it's just...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha
Shure: 就忍不住
Shure: I just can't hold it in.
Lucia: 不好意思法雷解释火葬场的你老嘴
Lucia: Sorry, explaining the crematorium, your old mouth...
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Shure: 保卫黄河
Shure: Defend the Yellow River.
Shure: 保卫华北
Shure: Defend North China.
Shure: 保卫全中国
Shure: Defend all of China.
Jake:我靠你说
Jake: Damn, you say...
Jake:哈哈哈你把这个12台电脑烧了哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, you burned these 12 computers, hahaha.
Shure: 好多黄油啊
Shure: So much butter.
Jake:一个烟头打过去
Jake: A cigarette butt would light it up.
Shure: 哦一会是不是要吃那什么来着
Shure: Oh, are we going to eat that thing later?
Shure: 我把麻将给卸了吧
Shure: Should I uninstall Mahjong?
Jake:行啊可以
Jake: Sure, go ahead.
Shure: 好好吧
Shure: Alright, fine.
Shure: 麻酱在哪
Shure: Where's the sesame paste?
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:没灯了没灯没灯了
Jake: The lights are out, no lights.
Jake:对啊对啊
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Katrina: 我的那根线在楼上还是楼下
Katrina: Is my cable upstairs or downstairs?
Jake:是好
Jake: It's good.
Lucia: 楼上
Lucia: Upstairs.
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Everyone.
Shure: 麻酱昨天放到哪里了
Shure: Where did we put the sesame paste yesterday?
Katrina: 就是在楼上
Katrina: It's upstairs.
Shure: 应该不会吧
Shure: It shouldn't be, right?
Tasha: 这里吧
Tasha: It's here, right?
Shure: 啊啊
Shure: Ah, ah.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 来给家人们表演一个卸麻酱好吧
Shure: Come on, let me show everyone how to uninstall sesame paste.
Katrina: 我需要一个超威班课
Katrina: I need a super powerful class.
Jake:电爆
Jake: Electric shock.
Katrina: 好像没找着以前的然后是
Katrina: Seems like I couldn't find the old one, then...
Lucia: 有还有
Lucia: There is, there's more.
Jake:呃这个可以显示
Jake: Uh, this can display.
Katrina: 啊你已经充满了谢谢
Katrina: Ah, you're fully charged, thanks.
Jake:我有很多电脑
Jake: I have a lot of computers.
Jake:我可以下载电脑
Jake: I can download computers.
Jake:但是你要先这是一个脆弱的硬盘
Jake: But you need to know this is a fragile hard drive.
Jake:对对对你要规范使用它
Jake: Yes, yes, you need to handle it properly.
Jake:它很脆弱
Jake: It's very fragile.
Jake:它很便宜很脆弱
Jake: It's cheap and fragile.
Jake:那那个那个充电宝给我
Jake: Hand me that power bank.
Jake:那几点零了
Jake: What time is it now?
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake:你什么专业来着哈哈哈
Jake: What major are you in, hahaha?
Jake:什么专业
Jake: What major?
Jake:麻将专业
Jake: Mahjong major?
Shure: 内个咖啡液还有么
Shure: Is there any coffee liquid left?
Jake:有有的
Jake: Yes, there is.
Lucia: 有就是这个
Shure: 他这个直接喝么
Shure: Can you drink it directly?
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Yes.
Jake:开了吗
Jake: Is it open?
Lucia: 开了吧我把我我把
Lucia: It should be, let me check.
Jake:没有开
Jake: No, it's not open.
Jake:变脸了没有开
Jake: Look at her face, it's not open.
Jake:你那你就热一个吧
Jake: Then just heat one up.
Jake:热一个好点
Jake: Heating it is better.
Jake:是没电了所以
Jake: It's out of battery, so...
Lucia: 我没电了然后断了前面的断了啊那我再来一个新的
Lucia: I'm out of battery, and it got cut off. I'll get a new one.
Jake:OK OK OK那你过也
Jake: OK, OK, OK, then you...
Jake:对对对你等他
Jake: Yes, yes, wait for it.
Jake:呃他应该你
Jake: Uh, he should...
Jake:你现在店很少
Jake: You have very little battery now.
Lucia: 三三点三十七啊对他就是今天断了
Lucia: It's 3:37, yes, it got cut off today.
Lucia: 他在一小时二十一分钟之后断了
Lucia: It got cut off after 1 hour and 21 minutes.
Jake:店很少可能不能可能冲到10%
Jake: Very little battery, it may only charge up to 10%.
Shure: 这有纸吗来张纸啊谢谢
Shure: Is there any paper? Can I have a piece of paper? Thanks.
Jake:想陶喆了
Jake: Thinking of David Tao.
Jake:忍不住了
Jake: Can't help it.
Lucia: 差一个哈哈
Lucia: Just one short, haha.
Jake:忍不了了
Jake: Can't help it.
Shure: 可才一个小花生
Shure: But it's just a small peanut.
Jake:这个水桶怎么用
Jake: How do you use this bucket?
Lucia: 就是他按压说的是那个按压按一下他就开始出水再按一下他就
Lucia: So when you press it, water starts flowing, and when you press it again...
Alice:按压
Alice: Press it.
Shure: 来我给你按
Shure: Here, let me press it for you.
Jake:还要等吗
Jake: Do we need to wait?
Lucia: 额不需要等
Lucia: Uh, no need to wait.
Alice:再按住
Alice: Press it again and hold.
Lucia: 楼上那个不需要等他是
Lucia: The one upstairs doesn't need to wait, it's...
Shure: 筷子在哪呢
Shure: Where are the chopsticks?
Jake:要插电是吧
Jake: We need to plug it in, right?
Jake:那我上楼接水我上去
Jake: I'll go upstairs to get some water.
Jake:这有筷子
Jake: Here are the chopsticks.
Shure: 这筷子昨天是刷了还是没刷呢
Shure: Were these chopsticks washed yesterday or not?
Jake:不用了我放楼接
Jake: No need, I'll put it upstairs.
Lucia: 上楼
Lucia: Upstairs.
Jake:一会他们收拾完房间
Jake: Once they finish cleaning the room...
Jake:然后你们也收拾一下房间
Jake: You guys clean up the room too.
Jake:收拾完之后
Jake: After cleaning...
Jake:有待我们稍微讲一讲你们要干什么
Jake: We'll briefly talk about what you need to do.
Tasha: 我
Tasha: I...
Jake:一般
Jake: Usually...
Lucia: 现在准备出方案了是吗
Lucia: Are we preparing the plan now?
Tasha: 出什么方案
Tasha: What plan?
Jake:没有处罚
Jake: No penalties.
Jake:就是加一些缓解
Jake: Just adding some relief.
Jake:然后吃火锅
Jake: Then we'll have hotpot.
Jake:吃完火锅之后把礼物送掉
Jake: After hotpot, we'll give out the gifts.
Jake:你好着呢
Jake: Are you good?
Choiszt: 哈哈哈哈
Choiszt: Hahaha
Shure: 这个就很开心
Shure: This is really fun.
Shure: 是的还有一袋
Shure: Yeah, there's one more bag.
Jake:我们还是到二楼吃火锅吧
Jake: Let's have hotpot on the second floor.
Jake:我们上去把桌子给搬中间去
Jake: Let's move the table to the middle.
Jake:一楼确实拿来连鸡蛋都吃不了
Jake: The first floor really can't even handle eggs.
Jake:还没弄好
Jake: Still not ready.
Jake:还没穿好
Jake: Not dressed yet.
Jake:卧槽
Jake: Damn.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:他的
Jake: His...
Jake:说帮我拍一张
Jake: Can you take a picture for me?
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 开什么
Shure: What are you opening?
Shure: 拍一张是吧
Shure: Taking a picture, right?
Jake:好对就这对联机太黑
Jake: Yeah, right, this connection is too bad.
Shure: 哦你们三个
Shure: Oh, you three.
Shure: 1414
Shure: 1414.
Jake:v three v three
Jake: v three v three.
Jake:呃摆拍
Jake: Uh, pose.
Jake:摆拍一下摆拍
Jake: Pose for the picture.
Jake:不要打麻将了
Jake: Stop playing mahjong.
Jake:发给老板看了
Jake: I'll send it to the boss.
Shure: 我们什么时候打麻将
Shure: When did we play mahjong?
Shure: 对不说有这个环节
Shure: Didn't you say there was this part?
Jake:那我就这样
Jake: Then I'll just do it like this.
Jake:作为一个老板
Jake: As a boss.
Lucia: 哇作为一个老板他们两个赶紧
Lucia: Wow, as a boss, they should hurry up.
Shure: 你们的严肃的办公吗
Shure: Are you guys seriously working?
Jake:你干活呀
Jake: You, get to work.
Jake:你这是干嘛呀哈哈哈
Jake: What are you doing? Hahaha.
Shure: 你得一边喝着咖啡
Shure: You need to drink coffee.
Shure: 然后一边守着手里工作都不停
Shure: And keep working non-stop.
Jake:对对对是是是
Jake: Yes, yes, exactly.
Shure: 哎谢明珠脸没露出来哎
Shure: Oh, Xie Mingzhu's face isn't showing.
Shure: 对对对好好好
Shure: Yeah, yeah, good, good.
Shure: 然后你在那个帅往右边侧一侧脸
Shure: And then you, Choiszt, turn your face to the right.
Shure: 右右右哎对
Shure: Right, right, yeah, that's it.
Shure: 然后再往后一点
Shure: And a bit back.
Shure: 帅往后一点
Shure: Choiszt, move back a bit.
Lucia: 有没有在想内个
Lucia: Are you thinking about it?
Shure: 然后再往右一点甩脸往右侧一点OK OK
Shure: And then a bit to the right, Choiszt, turn your face right. OK, OK.
Jake:就上新闻
Jake: It's going on the news.
Jake:你莫不也不过这样
Jake: You can't, not like this.
Shure: OK OK OK
Shure: OK, OK, OK.
Shure: 无敌
Shure: Invincible.
Tasha: 这这个没开启
Tasha: This one isn't turned on.
Jake:这个电脑少拍了
Jake: This computer wasn't photographed.
Jake:少拍几台电脑
Jake: Missed a few computers.
Choiszt: 啊
Choiszt: Ah.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 怎么摸鱼呢
Shure: How are you slacking off?
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 可以
Jake:这个一般是什么创业劲头是吧
Jake:等到这个市值百亿的时候
Shure: 对
Jake:这张照片
Shure: 然后就是雷总杨总
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake:对对对
Jake:交配一下
Tasha: 啊哈
Tasha: 开始第二波
Jake:我怎么交配
Alice:这眼影盘比较贵我舍不得
Tasha: 嗯哼
Shure: 所以你没有看到我刚才给你发的视频
Shure: 在放安普
Shure: 我很伤心
Jake:可能啊你
Jake:你们俩在你们俩在互相传
Jake:哦哦哦来来来
Jake:打扫了
Jake: All cleaned up.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 怎么切我歌呢
Shure: Why did you skip my song?
Katrina: 晶晶
Katrina: Jingjing
Shure: 哎很伤心
Shure: Hey, that's disappointing.
Shure: 还没满day
Shure: It hasn't even been a full day.
Shure: 陪你走到Sunday呢
Shure: I was gonna stay with you till Sunday.
Jake:哎是丧
Jake: Yeah, that's a bummer.
Shure: 可以可以可以
Shure: Alright, alright, alright.
Jake:去吧
Jake: Go ahead.
Jake:可以啊对对
Jake: Sure, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 好嘞谢谢你
Shure: Alright, thank you.
Jake:帮忙整理整理
Jake: Help tidy up a bit.
Katrina: 去厕所扔一下垃圾
Katrina: Take the trash to the bathroom.
Jake:对门口有好多垃圾
Jake: There's a lot of trash by the door.
Jake:就门后面
Jake: Just behind the door.
Jake:门后面垃圾是归谁管
Jake: Who's responsible for the trash behind the door?
Jake:这些啊我们纸盒还有机会
Jake: These boxes, we still have a chance.
Jake:要吗啊挑一挑
Jake: Want them? Sort them out.
Lucia: 额纸盒有几个我挑
Lucia: Umm, let me pick a few boxes.
Jake:哦哦哦就我我我OK
Jake: Oh, oh, oh, me, me, me, OK.
Shure: 咱们这有酱油来着吗
Shure: Do we have any soy sauce here?
Tasha: 没有
Tasha: No.
Lucia: 酱油没有
Lucia: No soy sauce.
Shure: 民宿没自带点什么调料之类的
Shure: Didn't the B&B provide any condiments?
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure: 民宿没自带点调料什么的
Shure: Didn't the B&B provide any condiments?
Shure: 水多了放糖
Shure: Add sugar if there's too much water.
Shure: 糖多了放水
Shure: Add water if there's too much sugar.
Shure: 这是哪个rapper啊
Shure: Which rapper is this?
Lucia: 这不是个rapper这是一个小众
Lucia: This isn't a rapper, it's an indie artist.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Lucia: 这不是是一个小众他没说
Lucia: No, no, it's an indie artist. He didn't say.
Shure: 是我问叫什么这个人
Shure: I was asking what's his name.
Lucia: 哦哦叫八拜星
Lucia: Oh, oh, his name is Babei Xing.
Shure: OK多少粉丝现在
Shure: OK, how many fans does he have now?
Shure: 网易云呢
Shure: On NetEase Cloud?
Shure: 觉得感觉可以买他点歌哎
Shure: I think we could buy some of his songs.
Shure: 我还买过好多比咱们小的
Shure: I've bought a lot of songs from smaller artists.
Shure: 破麻酱
Shure: Broken sesame paste.
Shure: 那叫一个地道
Shure: That was so authentic.
Shure: 嘀嗒嘀嘀嗒嘀嗒
Shure: Tick tock, tick tock, tick tock.
Shure: 是吧就是除了其他一个
Shure: Right, apart from everything else...
Choiszt: 卧槽
Choiszt: Damn.
Shure: 完了水加多了
Shure: Oh no, added too much water.
Jake:这么为什么能拍出这种照片是吗
Jake: How could you take such a photo?
Jake:这个很难reason
Jake: This is really hard to reason.
Jake:我拍了一个这个
Jake: I took this one.
Lucia: 哦吼
Lucia: Oh wow.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: Pretty impressive.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Not bad.
Jake:现在可以去了
Jake: Now we can go.
Jake:插上电我们对齐就可以去
Jake: Plug it in, align it, and we can go.
Shure: 我卸好麻酱了
Shure: I've finished with the sesame paste.
Shure: 但是麻酱是淡的
Shure: But the sesame paste is bland.
Shure: 咱们没有酱油
Shure: We don't have soy sauce.
Jake:试着开机
Jake: Try turning it on.
Shure: 所以可以加点盐
Shure: So we can add some salt.
Katrina: 哦他没开我以为开了
Katrina: Oh, it's not on, I thought it was.
Jake:看看你的店
Jake: Check your store.
Jake:帅
Jake: Cool.
Shure: 我的一直在脸上
Shure: Mine's always on my face.
Shure: 所以他一定是100%
Shure: So it must be 100%.
Katrina: 我这个应该可以了百分之十三了
Katrina: I think mine is at 13%.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 没有多余的
Shure: No extras.
Lucia: 可以了
Lucia: It's fine.
Shure: 皮套之类的东西吗
Shure: Like any extra pouches or stuff?
Shure: 皮套之类的
Shure: Any extra pouches?
Shure: 就是扎头发那种
Shure: Like hair ties or something?
Katrina: 哦皮筋啊
Katrina: Oh, hair ties?
Shure: 对皮筋
Shure: Yeah, hair ties.
Jake:呀你这鞋还是同款的呀
Jake: Wow, you got the same shoes!
Jake:怎么做到的
Jake: How did you do it?
Shure: 呃也不是
Shure: Uh, not really.
Shure: 就是买了点彩虹元素
Shure: I just bought some rainbow elements.
Shure: 但是本人并不是的
Shure: But I'm not actually...
Tasha: 哇还挺好看的
Tasha: Wow, they look pretty good.
Shure: 我要把头发扎起来太长了
Shure: I need to tie up my hair, it's too long.
Tasha: 以假乱真一朵
Tasha: Looks so real.
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Tasha: 嘿好
Tasha: Hey, nice.
Tasha: 不会谢掉吧
Tasha: It won't fall off, right?
Jake:火这糖怎么办
Jake: What should we do with this sugar?
Jake:给它融了倒掉是吧
Jake: Melt it and pour it out, right?
Jake:呃我看一下
Jake: Uh, let me see.
Jake:问一下
Jake: I'll ask.
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello?
Lucia: 怎样怎样
Lucia: How's it going?
Jake:哎右下角有一个这个USB看到对
Jake: Hey, there's a USB in the bottom right corner, see it?
Jake:然后退出退出
Jake: Then exit, exit
Lucia: 你这里有一个输入法
Lucia: You have an input method here
Shure: 我可以扒你的裤子吗
Shure: Can I pull down your pants?
Lucia: 我帮你挪一下可以吗
Lucia: Can I help you move it?
Jake:啊不用不用
Jake: Oh no, no need
Tasha: 天哪
Tasha: Oh my god
Lucia: 最下下面的这个就是退出号
Lucia: The bottom one here is the exit button
Katrina: 这是边牧吧
Katrina: Is this a Border Collie?
Tasha: 重新
Tasha: Restart
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's going on?
Tasha: 我说重新拿一瓶吧能能
Tasha: I said, let's get a new bottle, is that okay?
Alice:桌上只有两瓶
Alice: There are only two bottles on the table
Alice:应该就是我放的那一瓶
Alice: It should be the one I put there
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Alright
Lucia: 那就取消一下再试一次
Lucia: Then cancel and try again
Alice:你们在干什么尼
Alice: What are you guys doing?
Tasha: 我在刷小红书呵呵
Tasha: I'm scrolling through Xiaohongshu, haha
Lucia: 然后接下来的我就可以照本宣科了
Lucia: And then I can follow the script
Jake:啊就是就是这个
Jake: Ah, this is it
Lucia: 啊原来不是统一的嗯
Lucia: Oh, it's not unified, huh
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Tasha: 没事干
Tasha: Nothing to do
Lucia: 一会等他们回来
Lucia: Wait until they come back
Alice:叹气
Alice: Sigh
Lucia: 我要我要给他们讲这个故事
Lucia: I want to tell them this story
Jake:这个故事确实挺好讲
Jake: This story is really easy to tell
Lucia: 不行您真的情绪太稳定了
Lucia: No, you're really too calm
Alice:欣赏我们的花吧
Alice: Admire our flowers
Alice:你看我们的就很有层次
Alice: Look, ours have layers
Alice:但是你这个就是一只
Alice: But yours is just one
Alice:上面就好几个头
Alice: With multiple heads on top
Alice:就这种高度
Alice: This height is unchangeable
Alice:这个高度是没办法变的
Alice: This height can't be changed
Alice:我好像单针的比较多
Alice: I seem to have more single needles
Lucia: 你你在这里操作一下呢看
Lucia: You, you operate here, look
Alice:外边纸箱吗
Alice: Outside the cardboard box?
Alice:要不先留一下
Alice: How about leaving it for now?
Alice:哦谢谢阿姨
Alice: Oh, thank you, Auntie.
Lucia: 他们俩
Tasha: 喂
Tasha: Hello?
Tasha: 拿快递是吗
Tasha: Are you here to get the package?
Tasha: 我想我问一下
Tasha: I think I'll ask about it.
Tasha: 你好
Tasha: Hello.
Tasha: 哎走了
Tasha: Hey, they're gone.
Tasha: 今天也不去拿快递是吗
Tasha: Not getting the package today either?
Jake:什么快递
Jake: What package?
Tasha: 啊嗯没有人拿要不下次再拿吧
Tasha: Ah, never mind. No one picked it up, maybe next time.
Jake:你要去拿快递吗
Jake: Are you going to get the package?
Jake:呃你说今天有些快递到了
Jake: Uh, you said some packages arrived today.
Tasha: 我上午的时候好像就说有
Tasha: I think I mentioned it in the morning.
Jake:会有然后你手机他怎么跟你讲
Jake: There should be. What did they tell you on the phone?
Tasha: 他跟我说他在
Tasha: They told me they are here.
Jake:他他说哎
Jake: They said, um...
Jake:现在可以
Jake: Now it's possible.
Lucia: 那要不把把那个
Lucia: So maybe we can...
Lucia: 就是啊这样就弹出来那个
Lucia: Just... like this, and it pops up.
Jake:你继续说
Jake: Keep talking.
Jake:我没再再再讲一下
Jake: Let me explain again.
Tasha: 他说他今天现在在
Tasha: They said they are here today.
Jake:现在在好
Jake: They are here now? Okay.
Tasha: 嗯但其实不是很重要的快递
Tasha: Yeah, but it's not an important package.
Jake:没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake:你你你跟房东讲你他让你怎么取啊
Jake: Did you tell the landlord? What did they say about picking it up?
Jake:你报手机尾号是吧
Jake: Did you provide the last digits of your phone number?
Jake:应该是吧
Jake: Should be, right?
Tasha: 应该吧我不知道9707
Tasha: Probably, I don't know, 9707.
Jake:你手机尾号是什么
Jake: What are the last digits of your phone number?
Jake:京东
Jake: JD.com?
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:京东
Jake: JD.com?
Tasha: 那他是房东拿来送来了吗
Tasha: Did the landlord bring it?
Jake:对京京东
Jake: Yes, JD.com.
Jake:呃是的是的
Jake: Uh, yes, right.
Jake:111707
Jake: 111707
Tasha: 9707
Jake:9707
Jake: 9707
Tasha: 喂你好
Tasha: Hello?
Tasha: 啊房东等会说去拿然后帮我们送过来
Tasha: Ah, the landlord said he'll come get it and bring it over for us.
Tasha: 好谢谢
Tasha: Okay, thanks.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈我觉得我比你要慌一些
Lucia: Hahaha, I think I'm more anxious than you.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Lucia: 您怎么情绪这么稳定
Lucia: How are you so calm?
Lucia: 这个好像也没有360
Lucia: This one doesn't seem like it has 360 either.
Lucia: 也是直接点这个呗
Lucia: So we just click this one, right?
Lucia: AI是不是收集到了一些很神奇的数据
Lucia: Has the AI collected some amazing data?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake:OK了
Jake: Okay, done.
Lucia: 就是也可能因为我不是学这个的啊
Lucia: Maybe it's because I didn't study this field.
Lucia: 但总之我经常这么觉得
Lucia: But I often feel this way.
Lucia: 这应该应该也好了
Lucia: This should be fine now.
Lucia: 啊你你现在啊
Lucia: Ah, you, you now...
Lucia: 啊那行
Lucia: Ah, okay then.
Lucia: 我拿你手机拍也行
Lucia: I can use your phone to take pictures too.
Jake:哎对都都行都行
Jake: Yeah, sure, whatever works.
Jake:有什么想要的角度吗
Jake: Any specific angles you want?
Jake:没有没有没有
Jake: No, no, no.
Lucia: 你哪个角度比较比较觉
Lucia: Which angle do you think looks good?
Lucia: 自己觉得比较好看的可以
Lucia: The one you think looks best.
Jake:哈哈没有没有不用看镜头
Jake: Haha, no need to look at the camera.
Lucia: 那要不看镜头
Lucia: So don't look at the camera?
Lucia: 一会发您
Lucia: I'll send it to you later.
Lucia: 还是发群里
Lucia: Or send it to the group?
Jake:群里可以
Jake: The group is fine.
Jake:对这个是有360的
Jake: Yeah, this one has 360.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha
Jake:要不然我就在这盯着盯到各位回家
Jake: Otherwise, I'll just stay here and watch until everyone gets back.
Lucia: 等到大家回来
Lucia: Until everyone returns.
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia: 然后再再那个用Windows自带的那个
Lucia: And then use the built-in Windows feature.
Lucia: 弹出
Lucia: To pop it up.
Lucia: 这外面是直升机吗
Lucia: Is that a helicopter outside?
Lucia: 哦哦sorry
Lucia: Oh, oh, sorry.
Jake:有可能是直升机
Jake: It might be a helicopter.
Lucia: 听着真的很像直升机
Lucia: It really sounds like a helicopter.
Lucia: 但这个地方有什么必要
Lucia: But is there any need for this place?
Jake:或者是飞机
Jake: Or maybe a plane?
Lucia: 这个东西
Lucia: This thing...
Lucia: 就您这还有一个正在备份的
Lucia: You even have one that's currently backing up.
Lucia: 哈哈哈不用谢
Lucia: Hahaha, no need to thank me.
Jake:谢谢谢谢谢谢谢谢
Jake: Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 我们中午吃饭
Lucia: We were having lunch.
Lucia: 你还没上来的时候
Lucia: When you hadn't come up yet.
Lucia: 大家其实在讨论你是不是一个AI
Lucia: Everyone was actually discussing if you're an AI.
Lucia: 哈哈哈因为情绪过于稳定
Lucia: Hahaha, because your emotions are too stable.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Jake:麻了
Jake: I'm numb.
Lucia: 我可以抄一下你的作业么
Lucia: Can I copy your homework?
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Lucia: 大家easy不会真抄看看又什么灵感
Alice:然后就
Alice: And then...
Lucia: 哎这个桌布好看的
Lucia: 我决定抄一下
Lucia: I've decided to copy it.
Lucia: 不过改一个颜色
Lucia: But I'll change the color.
Lucia: 没有开玩笑开玩笑
Lucia: Just kidding, just kidding.
Lucia: 这个还行
Lucia: This is okay.
Lucia: 但不是我想要的那种颜色
Lucia: But it's not the color I want.
Lucia: 可以先加进去
Lucia: I can add it first.
Lucia: 然后慢慢删
Lucia: And then slowly remove it.
Lucia: 我觉得我现在那几个装饰
Lucia: I think my current decorations...
Lucia: 都还是墙面的装饰
Lucia: Are still all wall decorations.
Lucia: 没有什么桌子上的
Lucia: Nothing on the table.
Lucia: 因为我那个房间里面没有
Lucia: Because in my room...
Lucia: 没有桌子
Lucia: There's no table.
Lucia: 他只有一个小架子
Lucia: Just a small shelf.
Lucia: 你那里面有桌子吗
Lucia: Do you have a table in yours?
Alice:你可以去看
Alice: You can go check.
Lucia: 呃可能会扫到
Lucia: Uh, might sweep over it.
Alice:无所谓我收拾过了哈哈哈
Alice: Doesn't matter, I tidied up. Hahaha.
Lucia: 啊那我看过了
Lucia: Ah, I saw it.
Lucia: 啊那我看一眼
Lucia: Ah, I'll take a look.
Alice:你看我我那有个桌子上上面有个灯
Alice: Look, I have a table with a lamp on it.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Lucia: 哦哎
Lucia: Oh, hey.
Lucia: 那你这个很好看
Lucia: This looks really nice.
Lucia: 我那里面只有一个架子
Lucia: I've only got one shelf in there.
Lucia: 就是像这种置物布局是一样的
Lucia: The storage layout is the same as this one.
Alice:今天不是一样的吗
Alice: Isn't it the same today?
Lucia: 但是就是它家具没有桌子
Lucia: But there's no table with the furniture.
Lucia: 它只有一个置物架
Lucia: There's only a shelf.
Lucia: 所以
Lucia: So,
Lucia: 我就想给那个置物架上再放一个
Lucia: I thought I'd put another small storage box on the shelf.
Lucia: 那种小小的收纳
Lucia: Like a small storage box.
Lucia: 收纳箱那种
Lucia: A storage box like that.
Lucia: 让它整齐一些
Lucia: To make it tidier.
Lucia: 啊这个小灯挺好看的
Lucia: Ah, this little lamp is pretty nice.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 我说那个小灯挺好看的
Lucia: I said that little lamp is pretty nice.
Alice:你没有灯吗
Alice: You don't have a lamp?
Lucia: 我没有
Lucia: I don't.
Alice:你只有上面的灯吗
Alice: You only have the overhead light?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 是不是很amazing哈
Lucia: Isn't that amazing, huh?
Alice:我以为我们是等比例复制粘贴
Alice: I thought we were doing a one-to-one copy-paste.
Lucia: 哈我们的房型是一样
Lucia: Haha, our room layouts are the same.
Lucia: 但是里面的东西不太一样
Lucia: But the stuff inside is a bit different.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Mmm.
Lucia: 搞一个蓝色的什么布
Lucia: Get some blue cloth or something.
Lucia: 把床铺一铺好
Lucia: To make the bed properly.
Lucia: 一定要
Lucia: Definitely.
Alice:什么材料包啊
Alice: What material pack?
Alice:材料包我得勾到什么时候去
Alice: How long do I have to crochet the material pack?
Lucia: 啊我知道了
Lucia: Ah, I got it.
Lucia: 我可以买一个宜家鲨鱼
Lucia: I can buy an IKEA shark.
Lucia: 因为我是地中海风
Lucia: Because I have a Mediterranean style.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Katrina: 干皮油皮
Katrina: Dry skin or oily skin?
Lucia: son of whore and Scotsman
Lucia: Son of a whore and Scotsman.
Lucia: 为什么这首歌的声音这么小
Lucia: Why is the sound of this song so low?
Lucia: finding father without a father
Lucia: Finding father without a father.
Lucia: get a lot further by working a lot harder by
Lucia: Get a lot further by working a lot harder by.
Lucia: being a salesman by
Lucia: Being a salesman by.
Lucia: being a self starter by fourteen好像不可以
Lucia: Being a self-starter by fourteen, seems not possible.
Lucia: 因为这个电脑有锁啊
Lucia: Because this computer is locked.
Lucia: 但我可以不同不打开他的锁
Lucia: But I can adjust the volume without unlocking it.
Lucia: 光调音量
Lucia: Just adjusting the volume.
Lucia: he was learning for something to be a part of the brother
Lucia: He was learning for something to be a part of the brotherhood.
Lucia: was ready to ski
Lucia: He was ready to ski.
Alice:这个是算你的吗
Alice: Is this counted as yours?
Lucia: borrow a border
Lucia: Borrow a border.
Alice:他是编织贝壳
Alice: He's weaving shells.
Alice:有海滩的风格
Alice: It has a beach style.
Lucia: 哎哦这个好好看哎
Lucia: Oh wow, this looks really nice.
Alice:可以搜用贝壳什么的编织杯垫
Alice: You can search for coasters woven with shells and stuff.
Lucia: 这是杯垫是吗
Lucia: Is this a coaster?
Lucia: 贝壳什么的
Lucia: Shells and stuff.
Lucia: 编织杯垫啊
Lucia: Woven coasters, huh?
Lucia: 我搜我搜搜看有没有类似的
Lucia: I'll search and see if I can find something similar.
Lucia: 虽然我可能
Lucia: Although I might...
Lucia: 我那个房间里面应该放不了
Lucia: I might not be able to fit it in my room.
Lucia: 杯垫可以找找类似的其他的装饰
Lucia: For coasters, I can look for other similar decorations.
Lucia: （歌词）to send them to the mainland
Lucia: (Lyrics) To send them to the mainland.
Lucia: （歌词）and the words gonna know your name
Lucia: (Lyrics) And the world's gonna know your name.
Lucia: （歌词）what's your name man
Lucia: (Lyrics) What's your name, man?
Lucia: （歌词）my name is Alexander Hamilton
Lucia: (Lyrics) My name is Alexander Hamilton.
Lucia: （歌词）and there's a million things i haven't done
Lucia: (Lyrics) And there's a million things I haven't done.
Lucia: （歌词）just you wait just you wait
Lucia: (Lyrics) Just you wait, just you wait.
Lucia: （歌词）full of it dead reading two years later
Lucia: (Lyrics) Full of it, dead, reading two years later.
Lucia: （歌词）see Alex in his mother
Lucia: (Lyrics) See Alex and his mother.
Lucia: （歌词）bed reading half dead
Lucia: (Lyrics) Bed reading half dead.
Lucia: （歌词）sitting around sick the sad sick
Lucia: (Lyrics) Sitting around sick, the sad sick.
Lucia: （歌词）Alex got better
Lucia: (Lyrics) Alex got better.
Lucia: （歌词）but his mother went quick murdering with a cousin
Lucia: (Lyrics) But his mother went quick, murdered with a cousin.
Lucia: （歌词）the cousin could made a suicide
Lucia: (Lyrics) The cousin committed suicide.
Lucia: （歌词）let me misunderstood
Lucia: (Lyrics) Left me misunderstood.
Lucia: （歌词）ruin price something new inside a voice
Lucia: (Lyrics) Ruin price, something new inside a voice.
Lucia: （歌词）saying Alex had got a fan for yourself
Lucia: (Lyrics) Saying Alex had got a fan for yourself.
Shure: 怎么突然又多了几个碗啊
Shure: How come there are suddenly more bowls?
Lucia: 可能是桌上刚收过去的
Lucia: They might have just been cleared off the table.
Lucia: 这剩的这个
Lucia: These leftovers.
Lucia: 反正碗都要洗了
Lucia: Anyway, we have to wash the bowls.
Lucia: 要不把它倒了吧
Lucia: Why not just dump it?
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 早上是蘸白糖吃的吗
Shure: Did we dip it in sugar this morning?
Lucia: 对哎呦妈呀
Lucia: Yes, oh my gosh.
Lucia: 我擦一下手
Lucia: I'll wipe my hands.
Lucia: 把这再带上
Lucia: Put this back on.
Shure: 加了点但加了不多
Shure: Added a bit, but not much.
Shure: 我不知道多少
Shure: I don't know how much.
Shure: 那些那些没有
Shure: Those, those aren't there.
Shure: 腐乳什么的没有
Shure: No fermented tofu or anything.
Shure: 老北京二八酱是吧
Shure: The old Beijing 28 sauce, right?
Shure: 主要怕有人不吃什么的
Shure: Mainly worried some people might not eat it.
Lucia: （歌词）oh ship is in the harbor now safe you can spot'em
Lucia: (Lyrics) Oh ship is in the harbor now safe you can spot 'em.
Shure: 美团现在送一点是来得及的
Shure: Meituan can still deliver some now, it's not too late.
Shure: 你美团点一下
Shure: Just place an order on Meituan.
Shure: 要不
Shure: Or...
Lucia: （歌词）America forgotten
Lucia: (Lyrics) America forgotten.
Shure: 腐乳和韭菜花这俩
Shure: Fermented tofu and chive flower sauce, these two.
Lucia: （歌词）may i fight for him
Lucia: (Lyrics) May I fight for him.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 点吗
Shure: Ordering?
Jake:没点
Jake: No, not yet.
Lucia: （歌词）and the damn fall that shot him
Lucia: (Lyrics) And the damn fall that shot him.
Lucia: 3525
Lucia: 3525.
Lucia: 好像也差不多了
Lucia: Seems about right.
Jake:不回来了吗
Jake: Not coming back?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:哈哈哈伤心哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, so sad, hahaha.
Shure: 有没有一点人服感
Shure: Do you feel a bit human?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 人服感
Shure: Human feeling.
Shure: 就是
Shure: Just...
Shure: 人肤感就是
Shure: Human touch, just...
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 人人机感和人肤感对
Shure: Human-machine feeling and human touch, right.
Jake:学到一些很难翻译的东西
Jake: Learned something really hard to translate.
Shure: 这怎么
Shure: How...
Shure: host husband
Shure: Host husband.
Shure: style感feeling yeah
Shure: Style feeling, yeah.
Shure: feeling of host husband
Shure: Feeling of host husband.
Shure: 我去楼上吃饭一会
Shure: I'm going upstairs to eat for a bit.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:对去布置布置
Jake:我们拖桌子去吧
Jake: Let's move the table.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Alice:为啥一看淘宝就困
Alice: Why do I always get sleepy when I look at Taobao?
Lucia: 物业
Lucia: Property management.
Alice:是个重复性的工作
Alice: It's a repetitive task.
Alice:我一看我就犯困
Alice: I get sleepy as soon as I look at it.
Lucia: 我去把这个凳子再给他们搬上去
Lucia: I'll take this chair back upstairs for them.
Lucia: 要不然上面凳子就不够了
Lucia: Otherwise, there won't be enough chairs upstairs.
Shure: 稍等一下
Shure: Hold on a sec.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 我可以上楼了
Shure: I can go upstairs now.
Shure: 带着一把凳子
Shure: Bringing a chair.
Alice:这还有板凳什么的
Alice: There are more chairs here.
Lucia: 现在都上去吗
Lucia: Are we all going up now?
Tasha: 毛都说的上去
Tasha: Mao said to go up.
Jake:都来了
Jake: Everyone's here.
Alice:哎呦我的妈呀
Alice: Oh my gosh.
Alice:吓我一跳
Alice: That scared me.
Alice:怎么还黄
Alice: Why is it still yellow?
Tasha: 嗯没有人
Tasha: Hmm, there's no one here.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 来吧我们摆锅摆菜准备开始
Shure: Come on, let's set up the pot and the dishes and get ready to start.
Alice:厕所有人吗
Alice: Is there anyone in the bathroom?
Tasha: 不知道呀
Tasha: No idea.
Shure: 没有吧
Shure: I don't think so.
Tasha: 应该没有吧
Tasha: Probably not.
Shure: 没有咱们都在
Shure: No, we're all here.
Shure: 然后那个那谁还在咖啡厅
Shure: And that person is still in the café.
Shure: 其他都回来了
Shure: Everyone else is back.
Tasha: 上面怎么这么冷
Tasha: Why is it so cold upstairs?
Lucia: 因为之前
Lucia: Because earlier...
Shure: 刚开空调然后现在关了
Shure: The AC was just turned on and now it's off.
Alice:拜拜我去上个厕所
Alice: Bye, I'm going to the bathroom.
Lucia: 确认一下真的没有人
Lucia: Make sure there's really no one there.
Alice:这个锁是好的嘛
Alice: Is this lock working?
Shure: 这锁是坏的
Shure: The lock is broken.
Shure: 但是我们不会进的
Shure: But we won't go in.
Lucia: 那个锁是坏的
Lucia: That lock is broken.
Lucia: 这锁还是好的
Lucia: This one still works.
Lucia: 左边这锁好
Lucia: The lock on the left is good.
Lucia: 所以大家在这里上洗手间的时候
Lucia: So when everyone uses the restroom here,
Lucia: 要养成先敲门的习惯
Lucia: you should get into the habit of knocking first.
Shure: 真的没人
Shure: There's really no one here.
Shure: 没有
Shure: Nope.
Lucia: 我开灯
Lucia: I'll turn on the light.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh, come on.
Shure: 不至于神兼兮兮
Shure: No need to be so paranoid.
Lucia: 哦这有牛奶锅
Lucia: Oh, there's a milk pot here.
Lucia: 这是他这带的
Lucia: Did he bring this?
Lucia: 还是咱们的呀
Lucia: Or is it ours?
Shure: 我的咖啡壶
Shure: It's my coffee pot.
Lucia: 当我没说哈哈哈
Lucia: Pretend I didn't say anything, haha.
Alice:虽然没坏，但是没有纸
Alice: It's not broken, but there's no toilet paper.
Tasha: 嗯哼
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Alice:拿一包进去
Alice: Take a roll in.
Shure: 嗯可以
Shure: Yeah, that's fine.
Tasha: 嗯哼
Tasha: Uh-huh.
Lucia: 啊太饿了
Lucia: Ah, I'm so hungry.
Tasha: 我也好饿呀
Tasha: I'm really hungry too.
Lucia: 让我看看这有什么吃的
Lucia: Let me see if there's anything to eat.
Tasha: 我们把绿豆饼吃了吧
Tasha: Let's eat the mung bean cakes.
Lucia: 我支持我支持
Lucia: I'm in, I'm in.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Lucia: 哈哈那我们下去吃
Tasha: 好啊
Tasha: Okay.
Lucia: 还是在这
Lucia: Or stay here.
Tasha: 要不要拿上来吃
Tasha: Should we bring it up to eat?
Lucia: 拿上来也行
Lucia: Bringing it up is fine too.
Lucia: 那会就放这个冰箱里行
Lucia: Then we can just put it in the fridge.
Tasha: 行啊哈哈好饿呀
Tasha: Yeah, haha, I'm so hungry.
Lucia: 哈哈哈可以可以
Lucia: Hahaha, sure, sure.
Shure: 桌子没擦
Shure: The table hasn't been wiped.
Tasha: 那我擦一下
Tasha: Let me wipe it.
Shure: 所以可能有点脏
Shure: So it might be a bit dirty.
Shure: 得稍微擦一下
Shure: Just wipe it a little.
Lucia: 我已经拿出来了
Lucia: I've already taken it out.
Tasha: 还有东西要拿吗
Tasha: Is there anything else we need to take?
Tasha: 我就问肉
Tasha: I'm just asking about the meat.
Lucia: 啊就是火锅用的东西
Lucia: Ah, it's for the hotpot.
Tasha: 对对
Tasha: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia: 基本上可以都拿上去
Lucia: Basically, we can take everything upstairs.
Tasha: 还有蒜蒜
Tasha: And also the garlic.
Shure: 蒜
Shure: Garlic.
Tasha: 啊那这些
Tasha: Ah, and these.
Shure: 蒜需要拿吗
Shure: Do we need to take the garlic?
Shure: 应该不用吧
Shure: Probably not, right?
Tasha: 那走吧
Tasha: Then let's go.
Tasha: 要不要把锅拿上去
Tasha: Should we take the pot upstairs?
Shure: 哪个国主侯国
Shure: Which pot, the main pot?
Tasha: 就在这个底下
Tasha: The one underneath.
Shure: 哦这有鸳鸯锅
Shure: Oh, there's a divided pot.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Whoa.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Shure: 牛逼啊
Shure: That's awesome.
Shure: 然后电磁
Shure: And the induction...
Tasha: 哎有两个鸳鸯锅
Tasha: Oh, there are two divided pots.
Tasha: 正好要两个呢
Tasha: We actually need two.
Tasha: 因为不是桌子很大吗
Tasha: Because the table is so big, right?
Shure: 其实一个也差不多
Shure: Actually, one should be enough.
Shure: 主要底料没有那么多
Shure: We don't have that much broth.
Tasha: 有人够不着吧
Tasha: But someone won't be able to reach.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah.
Shure: 牛油底料很多
Shure: There's a lot of beef broth.
Shure: 但是清汤的和菌汤的只有一个
Shure: But we only have one clear broth and mushroom broth.
Tasha: 清汤的一个菌汤
Tasha: One clear broth and one mushroom.
Shure: 啊不是
Shure: No, wait.
Shure: 就是菌只有菌汤的
Shure: We only have mushroom broth.
Tasha: 只有菌汤
Tasha: Only mushroom broth?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 要不就一个纯蜡的
Shure: How about one clear broth?
Shure: 然后一个那什么的
Shure: And one of something else.
Tasha: 行
Tasha: Okay.
Shure: 但是有那么多电磁炉吗
Shure: But do we have that many induction cookers?
Tasha: 要不要洗一下电磁炉
Tasha: Should we clean the induction cookers?
Tasha: 哪有电磁炉
Tasha: Where are the induction cookers?
Shure: 有的有的
Shure: We have them.
Tasha: 这有有两个
Tasha: There are two here.
Tasha: 还楼上还有个卡式炉呢所以够
Tasha: And there's another portable stove upstairs, so it's enough.
Shure: 行那你拿一个电磁炉吧
Shure: Okay, then you take one induction cooker.
Shure: 你拿着这个我拿
Shure: You take this, I'll grab...
Tasha: 呃我我还要拿食材
Tasha: Uh, I still need to get the ingredients.
Shure: 那先先上去一趟
Shure: Then let's go up first.
Tasha: 楼上有一个卡式炉
Tasha: There's a butane stove upstairs.
Tasha: 再拿一个电磁炉就行
Tasha: Just grab an induction cooker too.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Tasha: 嘿
Tasha: Hey.
Tasha: 在这里
Tasha: Over here.
Shure: 插排拿过来
Shure: Bring the power strip over.
Shure: 插排不够长吧
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough, is it?
Shure: 够吗
Shure: Is it enough?
Shure: 插排不够长
Shure: The power strip isn't long enough.
Shure: 再接个插排
Shure: Let's connect another power strip.
Jake:打牌不够长
Jake: The power strip isn't long enough.
Jake:再接呗再接一个
Jake: Let's just connect another one.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 排接排
Shure: Connect strip to strip.